mais messieurs bonjour alors financier
c'est lui olivier et voici robert
professeur de communication en fait on
fait tous les deux le même métier on
fait la formation pour les cadres
dirigeants
ce dont on aimerait vous parler c'est
surtout partager avec vous en fait notre
vision de la formation des dirigeants
alors vous allez voir comme est à peu
près en désaccord sur tout mais vous
allez voir peut-être voir aussi pourquoi
nous travaillons depuis 25 ans semble en
fait nous avons au moins un point commun
la communication c'est comme la finance
les riches s'enrichissent et les pauvres
s'appauvrissent
je m'explique oui il a dû vous arrivez
comme à moi de passer cinq minutes avec
une personne et puis vous sortir bien
plein d'énergie d'avoir envie de faire
un de mener un projet avec cette
personne moi il m'est arrivé aussi passé
le 1er août avec quelqu'un et puis de me
sentir complètement épuisé d'avoir envie
de m'enfuir de mettre fin à la relation
avec la personne
tout se passe pour moi comme si j'avais
un stock d'énergie une batterie dont le
niveau de fluctuer au gré de mes
relations avec les autres si leurs
relations sont bonnes si des échanges
nourrissent mes besoins psychologiques
je suis plein d'énergie je suis plein
d'énergie pour mener les choses de la
vie
je plein d'énergie pour en donner aux
autres si jamais les échanges sont de
mauvaise qualité
le niveau de mada torride baisse je
deviens défensif je deviens avare je
suis un peu avec mon énergie comme
harpagon avec sa cassette
or nous savons tous que en fait si on
veut recevoir il faut qu'on donne ou
plus précisément on va recevoir d'autant
plus d'énergie des gens qu'on leur aura
donné en toute générosité
sans rien attendre en retour est un
robert c'est notre sujet la cad rapport
avec les clés cultiver du gène donner de
l'énergie aux gens c'est le fondement du
leadership
ça joue sur la motivation des gens ça va
avoir un impact sur leur satisfaction au
travail sur leur équilibre émotionnel au
travail
alors c'est vrai olivier et ses amis ne
sommes pas étranger à ça que c'est pas
ce qu'on voit tous les jours en
entreprise aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
voit entreprises on voit déjà en sous
pression on pompe leur batterie sans
leur donner la possibilité de la
recharger on voit des exigences de
rentabilité et de performance toujours
plus importante
sous l'influencé des marchés financiers
pour moi quand chaque fois je suis en
entreprise je me dis quel gâchis de
talents des amis ne pense que aux
chiffres et aux court terme
ah oui bien sûr c'est comme ça qu'on
voit la fidh en soi écoute je vais
utiliser de métaphores et j'espère que
je vais y être convaincre que ce n'est
pas le cas imagine que j'ai un petit
cochon qui est très spécial parce qu'en
fait il produit de l'or toutes les
semaines et pour des raisons
personnelles je voudrais te le vendre ce
petit cochon il faudrait savoir quelles
sont les questions que tu vas te poser
pour pouvoir me proposer un prix pour
mon petit cochon comme les produits ah
ça c'est très simple il produit 42 kg
drame de doha dix neuf cars à toutes les
semaines le mardi matin à 10h 15
pétantes et caisses quand même coûté au
merveilleux rien du tout pour l'instant
je lui donne que de l'eau et de l'amour
et cette belle histoire d'amour quand
même temps il va durer a pendant combien
de temps
mon petit cochon va produire de l'or et
sur quelle période et quelle quantité
ça c'est la vraie question en fait ça
c'est la question la plus importante
parce qu'imaginez que je lui vends mon
petit cochon et qui devient triste en
fait il va plus produire ou contrer et
va produire pendant une semaine pendant
un mois
pendant dix ans ça j'en sais rien et qui
est la réponse à cette question bien
évidemment personne alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait
puisqu'on en a pas de réponse en fait on
n'a pas de réponse parce que ça vient du
futur et le futur personne ne le connaît
alors on va l'inventer on va faire des
scénarios on va le faire de la
prédiction
on va en fait vous savez quoi on va
rêver et dès qu'on parle de rêve on
parle d'émotion si hier j'ai passé une
merveilleuse soirée le futur je vois
différemment le futur ce rêve va être
totalement différents de ceux ci de
celui qui va qui va exister si
auparavant
j'ai eu des crampes d'estomac et là on
voit bien que on ne parle pas de
chiffres en finance les comptables parle
de chiffres nous les comptables
effectivement regarde le passé mais nous
qu'est ce qu'on fait on regarde le futur
et uniquement le futur et c'est pour ça
que vous prenez une entreprise qui vient
juste de démarrer
qui n'a jamais fait ne serait-ce qu'un
chiffre 15 euros de profits et bien peu
valeur des milliards là vous avez les
sens la beauté de la finance la finance
tu vois c'est du rêve et de l'émotion
comme une belle histoire d'amour ni
convaincu j'espère c'est une belle
histoire ouais mais je me demande si
c'est du rêve de la chimère j'ai
l'impression qu'avec vous le bonheur est
toujours pour demain
et puis pour donner du rêve à
quelques-uns quelle violence pour les
autres est-ce qu'on se préoccupe du prix
à payer je crois que les marchés
financiers qui stimule sont totalement
décalée de la réalité que les gens
birmans vivent l'entreprise attend des
marchés ne sont pas décalé par rapport à
la réalité des marchés sont en avance
par rapport à la réalité économique
effectivement il détruit ce qui doit
être détruit mais pour quoi faire pour
permettre l'éclosion de la prochaine
vague pour préserver l'avenir je vais
vous donner un exemple il ya une
recherche très intéressante qui a montré
que sur les 25 dernières années
pas une seule entreprise a réussi à
conserver un réel avantage compétitif
pendant plus de dix ans alors je vais
reprendre le même exemple que d'autres
intervenants
regardez cet iphone et est arrivé sur le
marché en 2007
on est en 2014 ça fait sept ans torres
trois en trois ans samsung est là il ya
même une entreprise indienne qui veut
mettre sur le marché
un iphone à peu près équivalent à
m'asseoir 3 un peu près équivalent pour
un prix de moins de 100 dollars en fait
on voit que effectivement
l'important c'est le futur est
d'ailleurs les marchés se sont pas
trompés imaginez la valorisation de
d'apple a été divisé par deux en moins
de trois ans alors que ses bénéfices ont
battu tous les records et dépasse les 50
milliards $ alors que c'est en parle moi
je voudrais qu on vienne à l'entreprise
parce que les marchés financiers c'est
très virtuel pour moi ce jeu de
destruction création bon qu'est ce que
ça génère un changement permanent une
chaîne du stress de haut en bas de
l'entreprise des émotions très fortes en
général de peur et de colère
bonds est bon je crois que les leaders
doivent s'occuper de ça parce que en
fait ça a un effet extrêmement
défavorable ça dégrade des relations et
notamment les relations entre les
leaders et le reste de l'entreprise
bon il a en fait ce qui ce qui allait
les leaders doivent mener
je dirais qu'en team n 1 de changement
ils doivent avoir conscience évidemment
ils le savent par expérience que tout
changement génère la même question chez
les gens quel va être l'impact de ce
changement pour moi
et la réponse est toujours la même une
crainte de perte perte de son de sa
sécurité
perdre son équilibre personnel perte de
son identité professionnelle et en face
de ça je dis redon comme je les dis
dégradation des relations les ors les
leaders doivent justement bien sûr mener
les changements organisationnels
mais ils doivent aussi accompagner les
transitions individuelle et là c'est
quand quelqu'un est en phase ii du
changement sans doute y va résister
quelquefois il va nous poser des
problèmes relationnels
on va avoir l'impression qu'ils nous
poussent notre énergie dans ce cas là il
est en train d'appeler à l'aide
en fait l'urgence l'urgence c'est pas
que je me protège c'est pas que je met
de la distance avec lui l'urgence c'est
lui de lui redonner de l'énergie de
nourrir ses besoins psychologiques de
remonter le niveau de sa batterie mais
tu va nous donner un exemple peut-être
je voudrais plein d'exemples suppose que
quelqu'un soit très agressif avec - très
en colère contre moi portent un jugement
très dévalorisant sur sur moi et me
manque de respect
quel est son message son message c'est
un appel à ce que je lui témoigne du
respect la considération et que
j'accorde de l'importance à sa vision
des choses
si je lui donne ça directement il a plus
besoin de me l'expliquer en fait quand
quelqu'un nous en nous vole notre
énergie
si on veut arrêter qu'il le fasse il
faut lui donner nos propres ressources
en fait il faut donner aux voleurs tu as
ce genre de métaphores en finance alors
on a non seulement une métaphore on le
voit plutôt comme des paradoxes et
d'ailleurs des paradoxes que des
dirigeants doivent absolument gérer
quand je parlais de vente y cochon et du
rêve
en fait j'ai dit qu'il fallait rêver
mais pour que l'entreprise que les
marchés croient l'entreprise il faut que
la crédibilité et cette crédibilité
comment l'entreprise obtient par des
résultats
en fait les dirigeants doivent être
capables à la fois d'avoir une vision
pour créer du rêve mais en même temps
ils doivent délivrer des résultats tous
les trimestres et il va forcer le long
terme il va forcer le court terme et
cette crédibilité elle est obtenue par
ce qu'ils excellent dans leur métier
actuel ce qu'on appelle le business
model malheureusement ce business model
il attaqué par la concurrence
et qu'est ce que l'on voit on voit que
l' avantage compétitif
naturellement commence à diminuer et
même parfois disparaître même
l'entreprise disparaît et donc là on
voit bien que
il n'est pas suffisant pour les
dirigeants d'excéder dans leur business
model il faut en même temps qu'ils
s'ingénient à le détruire pour pouvoir
renouveler l'entreprise on est en pleine
folie oui on est en pleine folie c'est
vrai que tu as raison en fait les
dirigeants sont dans une situation
schizophrénique et est ce qu'ils vont
faire comme tu l'as vu comme tu l'a
indiqué il va en prendre
ils vont avoir du stress ils vont
devenir rigide ils vont se bloquer et
ils vont sarko buté sur le passé rappelé
mon iphone là cet iphone n'a pas été
créé par apple savez par qui il a été
créé nokia
quand deux villes surprenant 1 en fait
comme si chercheurs l'ont présentée aux
dirigeants de nokia
ses dirigeants ont dit attendez c'est
pas téléphone c'est un vrai nokia ya pas
de touche et en plus il est trop cher à
produire
en fait on voit la difficulté que on a
tous à imaginer un futur différent de
celui qu'on connaît et ça c'est d'autant
plus vrai qu'on a eu du succès dans le
passé
en fait tu vois là je crois qu'on touche
à l'essence même de notre métier de
formateur
notre métier c'est d'aider les
dirigeants leur permettre de mieux
comprendre et probablement de mieux
gérer des situations paradoxales qui
sont en fait beaucoup plus complète
qu'on imagine et c'est pas comment tu
perçois ça bon jeu olivier je crois que
cette fois on se rejoint à dents c'est
vrai notre rôle de formateur c'est
d'aider à la transformation et ça doit
se marquer dans ma manière d'enseigner
face à la complexité dont par l'olivier
arrêtons de juxtaposer un cours de
marketing un cours de finance un cours
du leadership mais abordons les
problèmes de manière interdisciplinaire
arrêtons de donner les réponses mais
amenons les gens se poser les bonnes
questions
arrêtons de délivrer la connaissance
mais mettons les gens en face de
dispositifs d expérientiel proposant des
métaphores des histoires des jeux pour
créer de l'émotion
en fait c'est parce que l'émotion c'est
ce qui va ancrer le changement c'est
l'émotion qui va faire
que les nouvelles manières de voir vont
devenir irréversible merci merci